Mẹ bát thành chiến bộ tổng thăm mưu các lượng vũ trang bà làm sắc nhận.
Ngà tổ đã chính thức hợi đồng của tập trận Eston Stainstry, chỉ lành thổ nước ngày.
Đây là họ đồng năm trong chiến lừa cùng gố sần đông cho ông.
Được tổng thư ký, Ngà tổ mắc rước nhấn mạnh, nhưng một phần quan trọng trong bảo đam anh ninh khu vực.
Theo thung tình được phát, nhưng mà bạn tìm tích ra phêng của bình sĩ khi tài điều khiển và vũ khi,
đã được chiến phá tở bà làm.
Cảm ề bay văn tài, á muốn chăm cũng đã hả cánh gần thình của Minnes Mazoyki để hỗ trợ cho lượng hùng quan.
Cô tập trận sinh xa chỉ phải ngày, sau khi bà làm thông bảo bán hạm số,
qua vây xâm nhé không phần.
Rồi phân tính nhận đình, Eston St.ry là cô tập trận chiến lượng mạng ý nghi quân sự.
Và đồng thời cũng mắt thông nghiệp chính trị giống sang về câm kết phòng tụ tập thể của Nato,
chương mọi thế thức về ăn ninh.